o latitude sua alta que falou dar que
seja muito bem vindo já mais um vídeo e
mostrar de que hayward 73 já elano e
hoje nós vamos chegar à segunda noite
não ligar o meu cabelo eu sei que eu
gostar tudo em parece um apoio nem xvii
e acho que dá porrada foi a mesma por
isso embora lá ok pessoal só que estamos
na noite de hoje eu tive que voltar a
pensar em 81 toda porque o jogo não tem
saída não sei porque mesmo só então o
vídeo phone 7 país que tinha em carteira
próximo em que eu não me deram bem e tem
47 negra quer sim do ovo ou uma foto em
vigor não não não não meu preço também
dentro da minha cabeça
calma
ok pessoal eu não ouvi nada do que ela
diz agora no fim do texto de mil
esta que o o desta que quase que me ter
um mickey que ia ser um mico é não
viajou ou vencer o osvaldo mas diz ser a
imagem do mickey é isso é
é e ela tava explicar que não está a
gente nunca foi capaz de dançar em cima
né
nem sabia eu sabia eu sabia vez é eu
saio daqui o eu sou daqui eu vou morrer
outra vez né calma apaga a luz apagou
tudo apagado tudo apagar tudo apagar
tudo porque aí as coisas que as coisas
que acho que fugiu calma agora não
conseguia ver nada
eu não consigo ver nada agora ok pessoal
estamos na segunda noite segunda
tentativa pelos vistos é muito mais
difícil e o outro anda aí eu acho que eu
estava a falar comigo não sair mas há
aqui uma voz muito clipe eu falar comigo
ainda por cima parece estar mesmo no meu
ouvido esquerdo aqui mesmo dentro da
orelha meu lá aqui o outro nome que está
aqui paga a luz apaga a luz mas é meu
gato pessoal pessoal é ajudar meu clube
agora que eu disse sou daqui e ataque
para hoje para pagar tudo a perder tudo
de novo
cama suja sushi jesus por foi ótimo
estado e podem mãe naquela anda atrás da
caixa econômica ou militar onde eu
também já passei um filho da mãe
eu tô aqui mesmo local a campanha eu
apanhei o pessoal estava muito foco em
escuro mas não conseguiu ver calma lá o
mec não tá eu vá ao estádio vai perceber
que esta noite está muito difícil eu
falar com o diego está aqui agora outra
vez meu eu mexo muito rápido canon ou já
voltou lá
caí e porque acho que é uma estrutura já
pagava se eu só peguei 2001
alguém explica isso é o que é isso meu
não mil para de falar vai lá para de
falar da questão
calma calma calma 1 mika então num
contexto go to wall da emel está
tranqüilo
a lei estadual caíto o maior foco em god
is so still está muito pesado meu filme
queime que apaga a luz apagou a luz
disse ok ok não faça espero ajudar que
eu nem sei como eu consegui ouvir porque
aquela luz parece mal para mim eu não
quero falar ainda apaga a luz mil que
agora ganhou cair mas consigo o gato
alto nos da manhã mas julguei que está
sempre aqui em cima de meu ataque agora
paga paga isso tão letal o ataque fica
com medo ficar com muito medo agora meu
calma calma calma são três da manhã e só
conseguimos passar em cada noite em que
desapareceu o que me chamou meu senhor
foi pateta não pode estar sempre a lei
que tu vai conseguir ganhar o tempo
calma lá o garoto
o gado está muito muito mesmo
i são três da manhã ainda meu tempo
demora muito a avançar na hora mesmo
muito carinhoso diz ali tudo
mickey é o nome que está a pagar a casa
de tomie quem era perguntar kindle só
que ainda calma agora cai 1 eu passo por
aqui filho da mãe filho da mãe passou de
14 para o outro - rápido meu carro prata
está aqui não se mexe nunca se mexeu
é lá que está a falar assim eu não
percebo esta voz do órgão observa
domingo e eu não percebi ainda mas
digam-me nos comentários pessoal o que
vocês acham que o uso não paga
apague osvaldo y eu vi e ouvi ea eu saio
dali o cai cai lá falta uma hora meu
calma calma calma contigo nem quem são
os dois aqui traz mim agora eu tô aqui
pelo ataque nem apaga a luz apaga a luz
apaga tudo apaga tudo apaga tudo apagou
tudo calma
eu juro que eu vi ele à frente meu eu
tava que a minha frente
agora já não está mais foco em god tio
estavam pizarro agora não conseguiu
nenhuma quebra pote não é não é não é eu
não sei quando a questão afirmaram ter
apagado as chamas todas lá parece estar
mesmo dentro da minha cabeça falar meu
ataque o meia itaqui me como é que eu
paguei isto pagar pagar pagar as coisas
pensar conseguir passar e consegui
pessoal tu és só nós ficamos aqui é o
fim do demo do five night 73 já alan
espero que vocês tenham gostado é assim
que o jogo completo de sair eu vou fazer
outras noites por isso fiquem atentos ao
canal então é isso pessoal deixou a
porta pois pretende um estado laico
favorito fiquem bem eu juro que amanhã
já vou com o cabelo fala aí
o